in his heyday would you like would you
let fine told me to you and I man I
think I have enough confidence is a day
yeah Jeffery first Jeffrey Jeffrey you
know what Jeffrey I'm over here for a
pool party you're gonna double me I did
it it was the butler in the pool house
I'm fun padded tatyana ali not get it on
that set number when she just when did
she become she got hot like adult hot
almost instantly
okay and Kev jumped and put her as the
love interest of his short-lived sitcom
really yeah the big house I think it was
called okay he uh yeah she was a glove
interesting and I smart and yeah you
just go and get the girl he had a crush
on since you were 12 you like what are
you doing you want to be in a show what
do you call that genre of black women
Chris it's Tatyana Ali chilli from TLC
falls in a new like very like white
people hair almost mmm it's like very
soft mushy she cute I don't know what
the column like I think it's softer
features I mean if I want to go in that
zone i'ma just slide into a kapenga area
I like Lisa you know me I liked her I
like Lisa - I was a they was good but oh
yeah hard Voorhees same thing this bad
statement since I was younger at the
time so I'm gonna say I liked it when
she was dead a bad thing like my lark
Voorhies became a batshit Luna so she's
crazy
oh I don't know she just went nuts
so she was she was she hacked her face
drop the ball yeah office ladies started
putting pictures of her looking like a
cat face lady like she had too much
current little Kim smashed her face into
the same wall yeah he's just nuts where
people just keep going back you're like
stop by the way cuz all in it all of
them have a point where you're like Lee
perfect could we do it but they're all
have a point where you can say perfect
Lou Michael Jackson Thriller the perfect
ruin her face I was a huge little Kim
fan
huge timelines I'm telling you it'll
drive you nuts you should do little Kim
had a point notorious kay I am can
someone stop there
can someone do like you know the black
and white video or the faces were
morphing time people probably done that
yeah has to be out there but whenever
they do that they do with like
meth-heads - they'll do like a really
pretty girl then she does like you know
three months of meth six month of meth
and bike and then I take the picture man
I got to get her back now while the
getting's good
I don't know if it's a rebound or a
player way back to the top I did you end
nothing on alfonso ribeiro no I found
something he's suing for tonight for
using the Carlton maybe he was me to buy
for I like to know that Carl that uh the
Carlton is litigious there's this video
saying it's a TMZ video that says sad
Michael Jackson didn't touch him cool
and then there was a guy the same last
name that's actually a hockey player
from Canada that was accused of
assaulting the nanny
oh that was my you blended your hockey
news in your car my Carlton Hockey News
does I do read those back-to-back yeah
you got to get different apps for me I
do every day go to Fresh Prince where
are they now and then the daily puck
yeah what's that
why is Jeff Jeffrey is killing it he
just spending his money he was already
an older guy you know what he's doing
right now he's got some reasonable
sunglasses on he's in hot
forty-year-old oh yeah he's got a hot 40
year old on he's just on hood body all
ass yeah he's just all on the paddles
I'm imagining this and I like it for
Jennifer I'm feeling good for Joe horse
he just gets noticed occasionally at
dinner oh thank you thank you yes yes
that was fun
oh yeah master William what
enjoy enjoy your meal Cheers
he's just living the life Alfonzo god
only knows he's all over the Game Show
Network I know I love him know him and
was a Mayo Lopez just getting younger by
the day that was smart
it's a smart move on both of their
partners they're like let's just I'm
gonna Mario Lopez was like put me on
every TV in every hotel yeah but it
makes me wanna say what I almost forget
that he's AC Slater now think of it more
as the junk advertisement television
face worse when he was AC Slater he
doesn't he looks amazing yeah for some
reason he's like world people was like I
kind of hate him I bet he could take it
out I bet he could take Valley now oh
wrestling that looks bad casting on have
you seen the reveal of jigsaw on
punisher yet no I have no well let me
tell you the bummer of this it's a waste
of time to why they make it a big reveal
he's got a few Nick's on his gorgeous
face this guy can get more than
all of us in this room he's got really
hey if he had double the amount of scars
he has didn't they do jigsaw in one of
the incarnations of Punisher and he was
like all super cut up and face
like a jigsaw puzzle yeah it's not
jigsaw at all this you know let's go
ahead and blow it for me he looks like
he can attack with the tiger lady
because Eddie goes Lenny you dashed my
cheek yeah bring his face was smashed
into a mirror to oblivion if we look up
all the jigsaws because I know there's
one there they did it up and I
think it was the one with Thomas Jane
yeah dude this was Tara the one but
after that this I mean the Punisher is
great so far well I loved I loved the
character and the guys watched the whole
thing but just five yes that's what it's
supposed to be he's supposed to throw up
a little bit your mouth yeah you're
supposed to see him that's why I thought
they were coming with yeah this guy's
still sexy everyone's an interesting
story about something masculine he's
done yeah I mean I honestly I didn't
even can you bring it up trying to find
one that shows it straight on just do
real jigsaw reveal Punisher it's see
that's what it should look like it
should look like I'll cut up
also because the thing is why he's so
furious too one of the things he's very
narcissistic and it was that he's a
good-looking guy who's now hideous and
now they've made him a good-looking guy
who looks exactly the same with some
battle scars like yeah yeah and getting
way close if you want it doesn't make
any difference he's like he's like steel
head turning looks like he didn't break
a mirror yeah
if I were Punisher and he showed up like
that I'd be like I didn't do my job you
won't have to buy a beer till one story
you'll never have to buy a beer again
you come out of me yeah you HOT probably
double to the girls who didn't want to
you they thought you were cocky
nothing you're vulnerable sir why did
you make me make you I am really
disappointed that should be if you could
screen grab that the one on the Left
should easily it's crazy disappointing
but you know what it does follow suit
yesterday Chris we were talking about
how Marvel makes them all their main
characters shave their chests well in
all Marvel movies you can notice and
Punisher when I noticed in punishment we
all we all in the green we noticed that
you could see he stubble II all over his
body because he shaves his body by two
things right while you're focusing on
the wrong thing are you like old-school
homophobic man I'll changing my own damn
didn't walk around dick all
willy-nilly sensual ass
pretty ass storyline taking
it all there's a bitch over his
shoulders a kiss up his belly it is
notice that his whole body is not even
recently shaved like it's just ee ee ya
it comes in stubbly can you bring it up
yeah bring that up oh I just didn't
notice the stubble I get it you just
need to be the stain I don't here's what
I know me and you are not fully
connected yet on our wavelengths right
there when he goes I'll look at it I'll
see it if you should just put up put up
a video of a guy's huge honker flopping
around would have been the funniest
thing to see Chris and then eventually
go all hell naw yeah I'm a grown-ass man
I'll wait in the lobby
don't forget to watch the next video
stay tuned now for part 2 I've always
wanted to say this but click the link is
that a thing we're gonna do click the
link